one of the things that i think
uh is so absurd about these mandates you
know we're having kids wear masks all
day at school i mean i you know every
time i i bike with toby to school and i
watch the kids
going to and from wherever they're
coming from wearing their masks like
it's nothing you know they're kids you
bike with him to school without wearing
masks you're not mad
no
we're not masked biking to school um and
you and you claim to love him
yes i do
um but
but
so you see both at the beginning and the
end of school all these kids coming and
going from school yeah and the thing is
they've obviously because they're kids
and they're more adaptable than adults
they've gotten used to it and it's not
abnormal to them and i did there was you
know there was some point at the
beginning of the school year kids were
uh
wearing them religiously and then there
was like a week or two where i started
to see a certain amount of rebellion
against them you know these are kids out
of school
right in the outside world where i don't
even think these mandates apply to them
and you know they were kids like not
really wearing them or wearing it around
one ear or whatever they were doing but
then they sort of seemed to go back to
it i don't know if it was one of these
waves of
fear that was inflicted on them about
new variants or or what it might be well
i've got just the washington post
article for you i was going to save this
for later but this seems apropos zach if
you would show my screen here yesterday
in wapo washington post is headlined
it's under the education
section students seeing lax coronavirus
protocols walk out and call in sick to
protest in person classes
well whoa right um most school systems
are determined to keep school in person
but some students aren't convinced
and then we have a picture of high
schools of a high school sophomore who
helped launch a petition and student
sick out demanding more coronavirus
safety measures or a returned online
school in california's oakland unified
school district
and it goes on and on and on here we
have a quote we were talking about how
we can make school more safe
and this this whole article just strikes
me as
so reminiscent of the safetyism that
we've been seeing since
2013 mass menos and that um greg
lukianov and jonathan height discuss at
length in the coddling of the american
mind
and until now
what the kids have been scared of is
you know racism and sexism and hearing
things that made them scared
and
frankly their own shadows and so their
own shadows now includes
literally a variant of a disease that if
they get it now will perhaps make them
immune will certainly make them immune
to it in the future but hopefully to
future variants that may be worse again
like if there's if they're scared enough
of this thing
to to organize to become activists
and petition their school to take them
out of school to keep them safe these
kids are never gonna leave their
bedrooms again
like and you know and this this this was
what we were seeing and this was like a
large part of what a lot of people were
objecting to and worried about about
this generation about both um
millennials and gen z of being scared of
their own shadow and being unable to
take risks and unwilling and not being
able to to see the world as it is and
embrace serendipity but this article
frankly is a perfect indicator that the
the sort of safetyism and then the
like
preformed activism i know what to do
i'll be an activist have just slotted
right in to covet measures yeah it's
it's more than an analogy right it is
it's more it's much more than another
version it is a variant of the same
mental disorder that underlied uh the
woke safetyism
and i would also point out there are
lots of other parallels too right so
it'd be interesting to know
what actually the kids are rebelling
against on the one hand i can you know
we hear a lot of course about the
nonsense that our kids face in school
right the level of it is high
and
i can imagine
that in some sense
you know not
wanting to be exposed to it manifest
says yes i'm not going back to school in
other words there may be a kind of
allergic reaction to nonsense on the
other hand
it could be a kind of mirror of what's
going on in the adult world where kovid
disrupted everything people
left their jobs their employers closed
down whatever and then they didn't
really want to go back to work because
they figured out how else to live or
whatever yeah and it just didn't look
like an appealing deal anymore and i
think the thing is school
is an abomination right it has become
one we have allowed it to become one and
there's no
excuse for this but nonetheless it has
been one for quite some time long before
covet covid and wokism have both made it
worse from the point of view of going in
and getting your mind upgraded it's like
you're constantly fighting the malware
installation that is being infused into
every class
and you know as i've said elsewhere i
sort of feel that the weird connection
between
so-called learning disabilities
and intelligence isn't really about the
learning disabilities at all it's about
the fact that they disrupt a normal
learning process which when it's bad
being disrupted is actually positive
that's right and so
i you know
i wouldn't
i wouldn't rush to judge a rebellion
against going back to school although
the idea of going back to school because
covet is making it unsafe is obviously
preposterous yeah right i mean you know
we just have you know
you can do this in isolation well
there's a dangerous disease circulating
don't you know well yes i do but there's
always a dangerous disease circulating
and this one's less dangerous to kids
than
others that we constantly expose them to
yeah
yeah i mean i just
how do we
hopefully
i i hear what you're saying about hoping
that the you know activism against
in-person school is actually activism
against school that's become so toxic
that it's um it's actually harming and
miseducating and shall we invoke
diseducating
um shall we coin that term diseducating
rather than educating um clearly from
this article that's not what at least
these these little activists are doing
this is you know this is safety is a
rona edition and it's it's appalling
and um the fact that
the fact that we're encouraging it the
fact that you know activism itself is
seen as an honorable
educational goal
by many and you know we certainly we saw
this at evergreen there were you know
long before evergreen blew up we saw a
certain faculty basically encouraging
activism as the thing that they were
teaching students in fact in fact credit
was given for it sometimes and during
the meltdown there was all sorts of
overt talk about
how they should be getting credit for
turning the college upside down um and
not be penalized for not doing the work
that they were supposed to be doing
right and
um
yes
it's
it's not it's not a sane moment
it's just not a sane moment at all
[Music]